take him away guys so long Kevin and I
won't be sorry to see you go delete my
browser history picker
loyal to those burgers to the very end
you guys with Myron are you dead yet
Kevin they're pounding up me with glee
they're going is your body intact or has
that been smashed the body has been
smashed people are crawling inside of me
it's horrible is it at least a little
bit erotic it's starting to get there
Conan I thought so
oh okay all right and when you said two
kinds of cockfight uh-huh what do you
mean well there's the cut where two
roosters are trained to fight one
another I know that sign okay there's
that kind and then there's the kind
where two penises are tripping your your
mouth is probably about to get smashed
isn't it no what I'm saying is that
they've been trained and they act
autonomously of their owners and you
just you have to make them bloodthirsty
and it's hideous to watch the people
attached to these penises don't want any
part of this okay well as you can
probably imagine this statues mouth has
been destroyed by now and so he's not
possibly able to talk more about penises
separating from bodies and having fights
okay I'm quite certain I'm quite certain
we'll hear no more from Bob's Big Boy
about rogue penises attacking one
another because it has nothing to do
with the sketch you see whatever Bailey
an inch